Thanks, for coming out to
listen to me talk about Vulkan.
I know it's the first
day of Google I/O.
And hopefully, all the
excitement of the first day
hasn't died down for you yet.
It's the last talk
slot of the day,
so I'm sure people may be
anxious to get out of here
and start partying.
But we are here to
talk about Vulkan.
And it's exciting
all on its own.
It's one of my favorite
topics to talk about.
And I've recently been
asked to maybe tone down
the Vulkan talk a little bit.
So it may be good for
you or bad for you.
Let's find out.
So let's go ahead and jump in.
So Vulkan-- lots of
rules and no mercy.
I've used this line a little
bit in all of my Vulkan talks,
because I feel it captures the
general spirit of how people
feel about Vulkan right now.
And it's a bit of a
joke, because Vulkan
does bring a lot of
good things with it,
but it does have a
lot of complications
that, hopefully, this talk
will help address some of it.
So a little bit of introduction
before we continue.
As you can probably see from
the program, my name is Hai.
I am a creative technology
lead on Google's Art,
Copy & Code team.
And my role on that team is to
explore different technologies,
to find out how we can leverage
them for creative work.
And some of the
things that I explore
are things like Vulkan-- how
do you leverage new graphics
APIs for use in applications?
And I started working with
Vulkan about last December,
a couple of months before
the February 16th launch.
I implemented Cinder's
Vulkan support
on Android, Linux, and Windows.
And then I subsequently ported
all the demos to Vulkan.
Cinder is a C++ creative
coding framework.
It runs on Android, iOS,
Linux, Windows, OS X.
And it's open source under
the Simplified BSD License.
Currently, the primary render
is OpenGL on the desktop
and OpenGL ES on mobile.
And that's where it is now.
Will it change in the future?
Probably, as Vulkan becomes
more popular, with the exception
of iOS and OS X, of course.
And Cinder gets
used in applications
of all scales,
anything from mobile,
to desktop, to very large-scale
installations that you
might see in Times Square.
Recently, Cinder has also
been used in the clouds
to generate content.
Vulkan support became
available in Cinder,
as I mentioned earlier,
on Vulkan's launch date.
Since Cinder is a
coding framework made
to be used in very
many general cases,
the implementation
is very much ongoing.
So what this talk is not about--
this is an advanced level talk,
so it's not an
introduction to Vulkan,
it is not a tutorial
on Vulkan, and it's not
an in-depth
examination of Vulkan.
And if you'd like a really
good, quick read on Vulkan,
RenderDoc has a really nice
Vulkan in 30 minutes document.
And if you need to see
some tutorials on Vulkan,
we have some tutorials
available on the GitHub repo.
And if we were all
to sit here and do
an in-depth
examination of Vulkan,
it would probably
take about a month.
But feel free, if you have
any questions specifically
about any of the topics, to
stop me afterwards, or find me
afterwards, and I'd
love to talk about them.
So what this talk is about--
the bulk of this talk
is how to get up and going
in Vulkan in a large way,
not just writing sample code,
but actually getting something
to production.
And so it assumes that
you know about OpenGL ES.
And it assumes that you know
a little bit about Vulkan,
or some other explicit graphics
API, like Metal or DirectX 12.
And since Vulkan
is definitely new,
there are some sharp
edges in Vulkan.
And I try to point
out the "gotchas"
and why it's important
to pay attention
to things like device
limits and the difference
between desktop Vulkan
and mobile Vulkan.
And there is a short
section on the things
to consider if you're looking
for performance in Vulkan.
And again, these are
kind of heavy topics.
So if you find me say
something that's weird,
and it's confusing,
please find me afterwards,
and I'll be more than
happy to clarify them.
All right, so to establish
a baseline between OpenGL ES
and Vulkan-- so
this question gets
asked more than
any other question
when it comes to Vulkan.
Is Vulkan faster than
OpenGL/OpenGL ES?
The short answer is.
Yes, but not from a direct port.
Vulkan is new.
And if you want to leverage
all the benefits of Vulkan,
you will have to change
some of your code,
if not a lot of your
code, and definitely some
of your thinking.
Vulkan on mobile's
feature set is
comparable to that
have of OpenGL ES 3.1.
However, it does go to
include compute, geometry,
and tessellation shader support.
It is an explicit API.
The developer has direct
control of almost every object
in the rendering pipeline.
The developer's also responsible
for memory management.
There are some new
objects and concepts
that do come with the API.
There are also things
that have similar names,
but function
slightly differently.
So one of the amazing
features that Vulkan supports
is validation layers.
And if this is the
first time you've
heard of validation
layers, they're
essentially an API-level
debugging error-checking tool
that lets you figure out
what's happening in the API.
It's a very dramatic
departure from glGetError.
And the general rule of
thumb for validation layers
is to turn them on at the
beginning of the project
and leave them on
until you've shipped.
The validation layers
are cross-platform,
which means the same
validation code gets used
on Android, Linux, and Windows.
And one of the cool
aspects of the validation
is this-- it's a
function call back
that you can supply to the
validation layers, that
gets triggered every time the
validation message triggered.
And this is what the call
signature looks like.
And this is what a
sample body looks like.
As you can see, you can break it
down into whatever granularity
that you need, based on
the validation criteria.
And if you're on
a platform where
you can't set break
points in the IDE,
you could definitely set a
break point at any of these.
And you can look
in the call stack
to see where the validation
message was triggered.
All right, so let's get a
little bit deeper with Vulkan.
Some friendly reminders
before we start--
and these are things
that if you're
beginning a port from
OpenGL ES to Vulkan,
it's good to keep
these in mind, even
though they seem very trivial.
The first thing is the
coordinate systems.
Vulkan's coordinate system
is upper-left origin.
And this includes both rendering
and texture coordinates.
This one caught
me off guard when
I was first working with it.
Everything I rendered appeared
upside down and kind of
backwards.
And I thought I was doing
something very wrong.
And so I went and stared
somebody down and asked them,
why is it upper-left?
And there wasn't a clear
answer, but it just is.
And memory management
basics-- in OpenGL,
you didn't really have to handle
a lot of allocations yourself,
if any.
In Vulkan, you have
to kind of handle
the majority of the
allocations yourself.
Buffers and images definitely,
and pools-- command pools
are kind of handled for you,
but descriptor pools are not.
You still have to point out
to Vulkan what you need.
All right.
So the first Vulkan
topic-- command buffers.
So command buffers are
one of those things
in OpenGL that you
hear a lot about,
but you don't really have
explicit control over.
In Vulkan, that changes a lot.
They are one of
the primary things
that you use to get pretty
much anything done in Vulkan.
And command buffers have to be
allocated before they're used.
And command buffers are
allocated from command pools.
The command pools themselves
must belong to a queue family.
And we'll talk about queue
families in just a minute.
And when you're submitting
command buffers,
command buffers have to be
submitted to the same queue
family as the command pool.
And also, when
you're submitting,
you want to minimize the
number of command buffers
that you're using per frame.
And when you hear this,
don't try to use just one.
If you try to use just
one command buffer
to do everything, you're going
to end up starving the GPU.
I also know that one
through experience.
It becomes quite difficult
to try to fit everything
into a single command
buffer, because you end up
having to do a lot
of code gymnastics.
So in order to ensure
the best performance,
you're going to want to use
multiple command buffers,
but minimize them
as much as possible.
All right.
So some sharp edges
on command buffers--
one of the terms that gets
tossed around with Vulkan a lot
is multi-threading.
And while there is
a portion of the API
that is implicitly thread-safe,
there are parts of the API
that are not
implicitly thread-safe.
You can't record to
the same command buffer
from multiple threads, but
it's perfectly fine for you
to record to multiple command
buffers on multiple threads.
And you can do something where
you can record multiple command
buffers on multiple threads
and then take all those command
buffers and kick them over
to a single submission thread
and submit all the command
buffers from there.
That's perfectly fine.
But if you're going
to do recording
from multiple threads, make sure
that each one of the threads
has access to its
own command pool.
And directly related to
command buffers is queues.
Queues is, again,
one of those things
that you hear a lot
about in OpenGL,
but you don't quite
have control of.
In Vulkan, again,
it's very different.
And it's important to understand
queues from, pretty much,
their moment of creation.
And queues,
implicitly, they have
to belong to a queue family.
And you know which queue
family they belong to
through the queue family index.
And there are a limited
number of queues.
And you can find out how many
queues a queue family supports,
by looking at a vkQueueFamiyProp
erties:queueCount.
And we'll get to
the queue family
properties in just a second.
But if you find yourself
in a configuration
where you want to do both
graphics and compute,
you want to prefer the combined
queues over queues that
support singular operations.
So if you're looking to
do graphics and compute,
look for a queue family
that supports both.
And the primary reason
you want to do this
is, at the initial
point of your port,
it just makes things
easier to coordinate.
Because if you start
using multiple queues
from multiple queues, you will
have to do synchronization,
and that can be a little
bit of a headache.
When you're working
with queues, it's
important that, if you need
to order the queue operations,
do it through
synchronization primitives,
and avoid using vkQueueWaitIdle
in performance critical code.
There are times when there
are legitimate cases to use
vkQueueWaitIdle, but a
lot of times there isn't.
And through personal
experience, it's
caused a lot of weird
bubbles in the pipeline
and stalls that I didn't expect.
And some sharp edges in
queues-- so not all queues
are universal.
The queue family dictates
what functionality each queue
supports.
And Android-specific
notes on queue
is that, on Android, there is
at least one queue that supports
both graphics and compute.
And you can present from
any queue on Android.
On the desktop, you
kind of have to go
looking around to see which
queue supports presentation
or not.
And this almost goes without
saying, but it's worth saying.
You've got to keep kind of
precise counts on the queues.
There are devices that
only support one queue.
So if a device
supports one queue,
it implicitly only
has one queue family.
So you want to check
these properties
before you start
creating queues,
because if you try to create
more than one queue on a device
that only supports
one queue, you'll
either get a hang or a crash.
All right.
Pipelines or pipeline
state objects,
as some people like to
call them-- essentially,
these are data structures
that have properties
that control pretty much
everything that happens
in the rendering process.
And they're fixed functioned.
So that means that,
once you compile them,
you can't really change
any of their properties.
There's a caveat to that,
since there are what
are called dynamic properties.
And the dynamic properties
can be readjusted
or can be adjusted via
command buffer operations.
And these include things like
viewports, scissors, or blend
constants.
How many pipelines can you have?
If you find yourself having
hundreds or thousands
of pipelines, that's
actually perfectly fine.
A typical application
may have that many.
And the reason, if you
think about it for a moment,
the different
combinations of what
you have in your
rendering states
can easily create
hundreds of permutations.
But if you're getting to the
point where it's over 10,000,
you might want to
figure out if you're
having too many
variations or too much
granularity in your variations.
You can also cache pipelines.
And the caching
achieves two things.
If you cache it at
the driver level,
it helps speed up the
pipeline creation.
You can also use a
selection mechanism,
to where you can use
a premade pipeline.
And you can do this by looking
at your pipeline properties
and using a hashing function
to select the pipeline.
Excuse me.
All right, so descriptor
sets-- and descriptor sets
are one of my favorite
areas in Vulkan,
not because I have a
fond affection for them,
but I had to spend so
much time with them.
Descriptor sets are basically
how the C++ side gives you
a perspective into the resource
that the shader will need.
And there's a few things
that may catch you
off guard about
descriptor sets, and we'll
go over these things right now.
The descriptors are
binding numbers.
So you can sparsely
populate binding numbers
on the descriptor sets,
but keep the gap small,
because unused binding
numbers still take up memory.
There also is a
max binding number.
It's not obvious, but
if you try to assign
a binding number
of, like, 32,000,
most GPUs won't support it.
And the validation
will call it out,
and they'll tell you that
your binding number's too big.
There's also a limit on
how many descriptor sets
you can have bound at one time.
And this gets reported to you
by maxBoundDescriptorSets.
And right now, if you try
to bind more descriptor
sets than your device supports,
you'll just get a crash.
And the thing with
descriptor sets
is that you will need to update
them once they've created,
so the shader will know what
resources you're looking at.
So the general
wisdom behind this
is that you want to
group descriptor sets
by update frequency.
And you only should
update descriptors sets
that have changed.
Updating a descriptor
set is fairly expensive.
All right, some sharp
edges on descriptor
sets-- once you bind
the descriptor sets,
you can't do any updates to
it, until the next iteration
in the command buffer.
And then you should do
that before binding.
So here's the one
really confusing thing
that caught me off guard
with binding descriptor sets.
This function,
vkCmdBindDescriptorSets,
there's a parameter on
there called firstSet.
And it wasn't obvious from
the spec what this meant.
And so I thought it meant the
index onto the pDescriptorSets,
which is another parameter.
And to give you a
better perspective,
this is what it looks like.
So at the bottom, you see
the function signature.
So this parameter actually
refers to this field
in your pipeline layout.
And it's a little confusing,
because there's nothing
that helps you figure this out.
Somebody had to
point this out to me.
Essentially, what this does is
it aligns the descriptor set
layout that you told the
pipeline that you're going
to use with the
ones you're passing
into the BindDescriptorSets.
So if you're running into a
place where you're binding,
and you're getting a
crash, or you're binding,
fairly unexpected behavior,
just make sure that these
two parameters align.
All right, frame buffers--
so frame buffers in Vulkan
are slightly different
than they are in OpenGL ES.
You can think of frame
buffers in Vulkan
as basically loosely
attachment pools.
Essentially, they hold
an array of VkImageViews.
The relationship between
framebuffers and render passes
is fairly strict.
The subpasses and
render passes refer
to attachments by integer index.
There's no ordering
requirements.
And the attachments
in framebuffers
must have the same
width and height.
In the general
case, you still have
to resolve any multi-sample
attachments to single sample
before you use them in textures,
not much different from ES.
So render passes-- as mentioned
before, subpasses inside
of render passes refer to
framebuffers attachments
via integer index.
Subpass dependencies-- so when
you start working with Vulkan,
you'll see a data structure
called subpass dependencies.
And from a high-level
perspective,
what this data structure
does is that it
builds a dependency graph that
you pass into Vulkan to tell
Vulkan the order
in which you want
the subpasses to be processed.
If you don't do this, some
GPUs will process the subpasses
as they see fit.
And this may not be
the order that you
want them to be processed in.
So make sure that, when
you're working with subpasses,
be really clear and
explicit about which order
you want subpasses
to be processed in,
if you're going to use the
results of an earlier subpass
in the next subpass.
And additionally,
on subpasses, let's
say you're on subpass
three, and you
want to use something
from subpass zero,
you need to preserve
that attachment.
If you don't preserve the
attachments, what will happen
is it will get destroyed
when the subpass completes.
And further on the
subpasses, if you
have subpasses that have
a multi-sample output,
and you want them to get
automatically resolved
to single sample, you can pass
in images into the subpass data
structure that does this, and
they'll get resolved right
as the subpass ends.
So here's a diagram
that describes
the relationship between
subpasses, and render,
and framebuffers.
You can see, on the
right, the framebuffers
are basically just a list.
And the render pass is
composed of multiple subpasses.
And there's actually no need
for you to share one depth pass.
You can have as
many depth passes
as you want, assuming that
it's within the device limits.
All right.
So the next two topics-- image
layouts and pipeline barriers--
I wish there was more time
to get in depth with these.
They're actually pretty
complicated topics.
So I will try to go over
them as best as I can.
The behavior of image layouts
is they vary depending on GPU.
Something GPUs require
very specific image layout
transitions, others won't.
The one thing you should know is
that all Vulkan implementations
will accept
VK_IMAGE_LAYOUT_GENERAL
for, pretty much,
all operations.
You will take a performance
hit if you do that, though.
So if you want to
ensure best performance,
it's best to assume that all
GPUs require specific image
layouts.
And set your code to
handle it in that way.
Transitions between
image layouts
are both implicit and explicit.
The image layouts can be
transitioned explicitly
using pipeline barriers.
And image layouts, they can
also be transitioned implicitly
by render passes.
And how that happens is there's
a field inside the subpasses
that asks you, what do you want
this to be once you're done?
You can also use the
validation layers
to correct any image layout
errors that you may have.
The validation layers are
very fond of screaming at you
every time there's an
image layout error,
so it's a good tool
to have around.
All right, pipeline
barriers-- if you use OpenGL,
they can be a little bit terse.
There's two things I feel
like you should know.
The first one is that,
while they do look complex,
they become kind of second
nature with some practice.
The other thing is there's
a restriction on pipeline
barriers within render passes.
And if you need to
issue a pipeline barrier
within a render
pass, the subpass
that you're going to issue
the pipeline barrier in
needs to have a
dependency within itself.
And you do that just
by telling the subpass
the dependency to the integer
index of that subpass.
And there's only two
types of pipeline barriers
that you can issue
within a render pass,
and that's VkMemoryBarrier
and VkImageMemoryBarrier.
All right.
So a little bit more advanced
on the memory management--
since you're directly
responsible for the allocation
in usage memory, just
like regular old C,
you need to do balance checking.
Make sure all your writes and
buffers are balance checked.
If you write out of
bounds, some drivers
will let you get away with that.
And what it does is it creates
these incredibly difficult
to track down bugs.
They could create red herrings.
It can create a situation
where you overwrite something
inside the vertex
buffer, but it actually
crashes when you try to do
something with uniform buffer.
So build some code around
error checking to make sure
that all your writes
are in bounds.
And flushing is something
that's making it's way back.
After you do any host
writes, make sure to flush.
If you have command buffer
operations that do a read,
all the things that
that read depends on
must be flushed before that
read operation takes place.
There is a slight
caveat to the flushing.
If you allocated memory with
the VK MEMORY PROPERTY HOST
COHERENT, you don't
need to flush.
All right, shaders-- so
SPIR-V is the official shading
language of Vulkan.
And it is a lower
level language,
so we're still using
GLSL for awhile.
It must be compiled either
online or offline to SPIR-V,
using either shaderc or glslang.
The same shader code can be
used on both desktop and mobile.
There is a big
change to uniforms.
Obviously, you have to
use uniform buffers,
but you can't have
standalone uniforms anymore.
Uniforms have to be
within interface blocks.
And the layout of
these interface blocks
are governed by
the std140 rules.
And if you've ever worked with
std140, it can be a little bit
complicated.
In Cinder, we use SPIR to
extract the offsets and size
information from
the SPIR-V directly.
And if that's something that
interests you, come talk to me
afterwards, because it
saves us a lot of headache.
The other thing is
that whoever is working
on your team on bindings,
or between the shaders
and descriptor sets, spend
some time understanding
how they relate
with the descriptor
sets and the shaders.
There's obviously a
natural relationship,
but it's really easy
to make an error in one
and kind of ignore that it may
create an error in the other,
because you do have to
keep them synchronized.
All right, so performance
considerations-- so these
are self-evident things
that we, hopefully,
all hold to be true
when we're talking
about performance in graphics.
Obviously, minimize
host to GPU transfers,
especially on mobile,
because that ends up
taking a lot of power.
Reduce round trips on any reads.
That includes if you're
using depressed textures
to speed things up.
And in Vulkan, very specifically
try not to starve the GPU,
because, when you
starve the GPU,
the next round of you
pushing data to the GPU
can easily over-saturate it.
And with respect
to render loops,
the best thing for you to do
is to keep multiple frames
in flight with Vulkan.
I find this, in Vulkan, to
actually be a lot easier
to do than OpenGL.
In OpenGL, at
times, I felt like I
was at the mercy of
the driver of what
I was doing when I was trying to
keep multiple frames in flight.
With Vulkan, you
can very explicitly
do this, because of
the nature of Vulkan.
So if you have more than
one frame in flight--
say you have two--
then you obviously
have to double buffer all
your non-static resources.
If you have three, then
you need to triple buffer
your non-static resources,
and so on, and so forth.
And this also includes things
like your command buffer.
And the command buffers
are a good starting point,
if you need to figure
out what resources are
backing that particular frame.
So you can start building
a dependency graph
from the command buffer back
to the resource that you need.
And so, since you have
multiple frames in flight,
you'll probably need
to handle the frame
rate throttling yourself.
This takes a little
bit of work, and it
requires both using the Vulkan
sync primitives plus some CPU
side logic.
And this is definitely
an area where you do not
want to use vkQueueWaitIdle.
I'm sorry.
Some of the Vulkan function
names are really hard to say.
And I know I'm screwing them
up, because they're a mouthful,
and they're really long.
So I apologize for that.
All right.
So here's something that
didn't exist in OpenGL,
but I think it may be coming to
OpenGL soon, is push constants.
So if you're looking to
do something really quick,
and there's not a
whole lot of data
that you need to pass between
your code and the shader code,
you can use push constants.
And push constants, they
don't require any buffers.
They don't require
any descriptor setups.
You can only push
128 bytes at a time.
And the limitation on
them is that you can only
have one push constant for
all shader stages, per shader.
In 128 bytes, you can
fit at about two 4
x 4 matrices in there.
So you kind of have to
be a little bit clever
in how you use them.
And this sharp edge--
the size and the offsets
must be a multiple of 4.
It's not really a sharp edge.
4 is the default machine size
for, pretty much, any GPU.
So if your size and
offset is not 4,
something went wrong
somewhere else, horribly.
But they are really
quick and fast.
And Cinder does have a
sample of how to use this.
And here's what they look like.
It just looks like
a uniform block,
except where the layout
is, it has push constants.
Excuse me.
All right, so most projects
will probably start on desktop
and go to mobile.
If you're not doing that, then
you're really highly skilled.
But for the rest
of us, pretty much,
everything starts on desktop
and then migrates to mobile.
So Vulkan-- the API actually
is crazy consistent.
Cinder took three hours to port
from the desktop to mobile.
And the only thing
that required changing
was basically the WSI, or
Windows Systems Integration,
and the swapchain.
And it pretty much ran.
So I'm not saying
that your code will
take that short amount
of time to port,
but you can trust that
the API's consistent.
The only other area that's
different is the extensions.
So that's for the API.
Now, the properties
are a different story.
So the properties
for the features
are very different
from GPU to GPU.
And those include things like
what image formats or buffer
formats are host visible, and
what depth/stencil formats are
supported.
So don't assume that
the two devices that
may be similar in capabilities
at their Vulkan completions
are equal.
I made that
assumption, and I found
that to be completely not true.
So if you must,
write a little tool
that queries the
properties of the devices,
so it solidifies
in your head what
the devices are capable of.
There's not a whole lot
of Vulcan implementations
right now, so you can
keep track of it that way.
But it really helps.
The other thing
when you're porting
is have a strategy to
find the best properties
for that particular device.
An example of this in Cinder is
that we have a function called
vk::findBestDepthStencilFormat.
And the reasoning for that is
that, on some of the devices,
the best one was 32-bit
float, while others,
only 16 and 24-bit
integers were supported.
Or at minimum, you
can use properties
that are known to work
across all devices.
All right.
The other thing that
you should be aware of
is 3 channel format
support is very limited.
And this includes both
image and buffer formats.
So again, develop a
tool that generates
a device support
on which formats
are supported for the devices.
And if you are relying on any
data packing on your vertex
or images, and you're using
3 channel formats right now,
you may have to change the
format that you're using, which
leads me to the next point.
If you're also staging transfers
between your source, your host
data, and your GPU
data, you may have
to transform the
data in the staging.
An example of this is-- let's
say your host format is RGB.
On some devices, RGB-8
isn't a visible host format.
So you may have to
transform that to RGBA,
copy it to the Vulkan
memory as RGBA,
and then do the conversion
inside of Vulkan.
The other way to
work around this
is to do a direct
copy from buffer
to image, using
vkCmdCopyBufferToImage.
There is a caveat to that.
I'll get to it in just a second.
But this essentially
does a bit for bit copy
from the buffer to the image.
So you can basically just read
your image into the buffer
and then dump it into
the image itself.
The depth stencil
copies are very
specific in their behavior.
And there's a good portion of
the spec that talks about that.
Compressed textures-- so
you should know-- I mean,
we kind of want to
know, mostly these days,
what formats are supported.
The thing not to
do is don't assume
that if it's supported in
OpenGL ES for the device
that it's supported in Vulkan.
It may not be.
One nice thing about
Android in this regard
is that all Android
Vulkan implementations
will support ETC2, and some of
them will support ATSC as well.
And just for completion,
the desktop support
is essentially just
the BC formats.
They may have slightly
more complicated names.
Excuse me, for one second.
OK, so this is the
last part of this,
going from desktop to mobile.
So again, not to harp on
image layouts too much,
but some GPUs will require
image layout transitions,
while others won't.
It's just best to treat
them as if they all do.
And this is a really
important point.
I encourage you, if you have
any questions about this,
please come talk to me.
I can't say certain
things on stage,
but I can give you
specific details
if you want to know
more about this.
So pay attention to
the device limits.
This almost goes without saying,
but again, it catches people
more often than not.
Most of the vendors
will go above and beyond
in certain areas of the
device limits, and not others.
And some device vendors will
just kind of do the minimum.
It's not because one vendor's
better than the other, it's
just the implementation, right?
But don't assume that
the same class of devices
have similar functionality.
They may not.
And if you run into any errors,
especially with device limits,
you can use a validation
layer to track them down.
All right, so that's
about 41 slides
of me talking without
showing you any pictures.
And let me fix that right now.
So I know that the
word "games" is
used in the title of the talk.
And I'm not going to show
you game engine demos,
but I would like to show you
render demos, if that's OK.
And the point of
these demos is to give
more credence to the fact
that Vulkan is up and running,
and you can do some pretty
amazing things with it already.
And so hopefully, these examples
are visually enticing enough.
Can we get to the demos, please?
So this is a
flocking simulation.
It runs almost
entirely on the GPU.
It's a flock simulation of,
I think, about 4,000 fish.
And essentially,
the fish simulation
is running on the GPU.
And there's a shark that
comes in every now and then,
and it basically causes
the fish to disperse.
The code for this is
actually open source.
It's a sample on Cinder.
If you want to get it and mess
with it, it's totally free.
Oops.
Stay awake.
The original work was done
by my friend, Robert Hodgin.
He was gracious enough to donate
it as part of the Vulkan launch
date efforts.
And the next demo
I want to show you
is also another demo by Robert.
And essentially, if you're
familiar with NASA's capture
of sunspots, this is what
the images look like.
So Robert wanted
to create something
that was a real-time
version of the sunspots.
So he just likes to
create pretty pictures.
But it turns out to
be very beautiful.
And the funny tidbit about
this is that, actually,
more than a few
people have mistakenly
thought this was the
actual NASA capture.
So this one, unfortunately,
isn't open source.
But if you would like the
APK to either one of these,
just come find me afterwards.
I'll be more than happy
to give it to you.
Can we go back to the slides?
All right.
So to wrap things up, if
you want to want to look
at Cinder's [INAUDIBLE]
implementation,
it's at
github.com/cinder/Cinder.
We're on the Vulcan branch.
If you want to connect
with us about Vulkan,
we really want to work with
you to make Vulkan successful.
Please visit this URL.
Cool.
Well, thank you, guys.